welcome to this video yeah we're already
covering round seven the final round of
the first turn so this marks them the
half yeah we have through the whole
event and the game i'm going to show you
here is swidler playing wide against
arnold swidler on fifty percent after
kind of a roller coaster tournament win
loss win loss and with candy was with
some weird weird games as well well
Anand has won two games never was in
trouble and simply showing his best
performance for ages so let's see what
happens in this game yeah another bull
in defense um but I'm going to say right
right now that this is not a boring game
so you shouldn't there shouldn't stop
watching yet keep keep tuned that it
will be a good a good interesting game
yeah as mentioned earlier it feels a bit
a bit boring to have the balloon all the
time as I stated quite often I
understand why why why they play it so
often but once in a while why not try
something else okay yes we are playing
d3 the this quiet line that avoids the
the endgame Bishop c5 and c3 yeah they
often tried this also also in this
tournament again note that this is not
on losing a piece but they tried
something like that this is what I
draken for instance played again tonner
didn't some in two two runs already i
believe maybe she also got a good
position as black maybe had some winning
chances even yeah the c3 vice villa is
some the somewhat i'm yeah i'm not sure
if i should say ambitious move but it
simply keeps a bit more pieces on the
board tries to get to a more complex
middle game
yeah oh this is perfectly normal and now
on a place 97 now this is this idea is
gaining a really lots of momentum um we
saw this early in the tournament in the
game and Drake in with right against
kayaking and in this game and raking
played the move deform makes lots of
sense of course kicking the bishop and
the idea became apparent after these
moves that black would play d5 soon
something like that is how it went in
this game and black car already looks to
be quite comfortable spill avoided that
he had tried default earlier in 2013 but
ok here's go for rookie one keeping the
tension and the center c6 we should be a
fall and now on our place bishop b6
which tape technically is a novelty but
very normal in other games they played
this first but it does not make much of
a difference special b6 default plate
and tonight a g6 in fact this position
has been played before just by different
move order yeah and in this position now
sweedler place they're very normal
looking with age three and then I found
a number of games with this position
let's say like 20 or so and in this
position black has tried all kinds of
moves rook e8 for example has been
played just recently by and then yay
diminish the top cuban player or bishop
c7 or all normal moves all intending to
just keep the status quo in the center
and maybe prepare for d5 very long-term
plan to equalize completely in the
center
um yeah and now I'm not is coming up
with in time the new concept for this
position and I think it's actually very
good one and maybe I'm not sure maybe it
is a bit harsh to say but it seems to
render h3 somewhat dubious in my my book
he took on deform surprisingly enough
but we saw the general idea but let's
see what happens here and now d file of
course yeah and okay here if you want to
do anything interesting as as wide yeah
you have to play you five what else is
there and did that on something keep
doing that something like that for
example like really just recaptures and
gets a very comfortable isolated pawn
position this is not great and the
bishop ears are also not great I mean
why does not in big trouble here or
something but it's simply not what you
want swidler played a five and this got
answered by me5 this got answered by
night h5 a very interesting idea bye bye
Arnold getting night quickly getting a
night quickly to f4 some of the software
so having some glitches hands a bit
strange night h5 yeah intending to to
get to f4 and we are very often in the
in the open games the night arriving on
f4 or f5 this is a real nuisance and
black you just managed to get get this
in the night to air for tourists are
already believe that widest is worse and
this is very weird i mean it's it's a
vulnerable position like plate as
mentioned like 20 times and no one came
up with
and it's one took some time he probably
had this Mary yet this idea over the
board or he was just rechecking his
analysis i'm not sure but this is
already very very tricky for white to
play you always have those nights or get
your king and it does not that's not
really a yeah it's not really much fun
to play yeah play tonight to f1 and
finally moved to look at is g3 trying to
really cover the square and hoping or
banking on this on this idea Bishop
takes Knight h2 to attack the night and
claimed that black has no good way to
cover it after this there is some yeah
this move for instance and it's indeed
good for white but black young has a far
better movie he can just take on EG
three this is leading to complete
disaster and quickly something like that
check it's just just using four wide
terrible position yeah g3 is just an
attempt to to quickly end the game but
not in your favor yeah I played night f1
looks very natural move like and very
natural move getting the night over
covering some squares on the King side
and freeing the c1 bishop yeah and okay
this move is sort of clear what else and
yeah what is why it's supposed to do now
this is just super annoying piece the
computer at first gives this is about
equal which really surprised me when
after a while it agrees that black it's
just better here and then f6 this is the
the big problem Blackwell almost always
have f6 in addition to all of that and
be able to attack the spearhead pawn and
if why does force to take that even the
effort is opening up and another very
big issue is that the d4 pawn is just we
care like
is always attacking it with those minor
pieces and white um is really not having
any sort of direct counter play this is
a very very uncomfortable position yes
Villa didn't take which I very much
understand even giving up the bishop pay
our top for all of that they played
Bishop situ after a very long thought
and he was visibly uncomfortable I had
the chance to watch some of the the live
video coverage and yeah well it's really
a terrible to be in this spot after 15
moves with white and you're really not
you'd already know what what we did
wrong it looks like completely normal
everything up to here but maybe white
needs to improve somewhere here I read
oh no around here black is already
better and has very easy play in the
next move is very clear f6 now you
attack the center the central pawn the
night on g6 are also nicely placed to to
crease the pressure on e5 and again it's
very tough to give wide advice if you
for instance just take it yeah and like
takes with the Queen and now it it gets
really ugly there are numerous
sacrificial ideas of course for this
night computer actually wants to grab on
c6 now and play this position which is a
disaster and the worst thing is that you
have no counter play whatsoever wide
absolutely none this is also as well I
probably think I never really considered
to take on f6 I think he did relatively
speaking of the best thing possible he
played night to g3 um and after F takes
d5 which is also quite quite an obvious
move
he took on g6 not not a happy move
absolutely not but what what should what
else should you do just just to consider
what what what could happen now if he
takes here with the porn yeah there's
there's even this coming immediately
okay check check yeah and white will get
mated in short order yeah there's so
much pressure already on the on the king
you cannot really play any any any
second-rate moves anymore something like
that okay besides the director
sacrifices says also queen f6 check is
also winning very quickly it's just a
vicious attack if you need to reduce the
the piece count near the king where this
is why after the capture only five he
played this as mentioned not especially
aesthetic but what else is there
aesthetic move to capture no black we
took Bishop g5 gaining at least the
temple yeah if you look at 95 here this
is a bit better than in the position
before but it's also not helping enter
it absolutely leaves you without any
counter play yeah you probably need to
do do this and the problem is that this
route only five now has somewhat
stranded something like here and shut to
see 700 probably win the exchange the
rook has no square yes with the plate
Bishop g5 which i think is the best dry
Queen c7 quite logical and now night xe5
was played yeah and we are carrying me a
very critical position now
um and captured rook takes yeah and here
maybe you should look at this position
for a moment and consider what movie
should black seriously you think about
it's not a move that I can I can tell
you that immediately it's not a move
that is winning the game but just to
maybe improve your tactical vision what
move shot down like calculator gives you
a couple of seconds okay i'm going to
show you the move and the interesting
movie as rook takes f to something that
comes quite naturally to a stronger
player who has looked at the position
simply because you you feel that there's
something critical happening on this
diagonal and you would immediately check
those sacrifices i mean it's not the
text sacrifice in terms of giving up
material but like those some those
flashy moves you would check immediately
yeah Alan took lots of time in this
position here and I can tell you right
away he didn't take so why didn't he
take yeah let's start with the easy
things I mean this is quite clear that
black is just winning him he gained a
pawn even to bishops week porn be king
easy yeah this is easy but white can
indeed fight on in this position and
with some gas on justification he can
give this check choices the critical
line that are none certainly calculated
now you cannot move them King and this
this is check ya out of the question you
need to play on the book back yeah I'd
here child will capture and okays upon
down but if you consider this let's say
white plays this move King h2 it's not
so nice to get into the self pin but you
probably don't have anything much better
and it's not such a big deal this
help in as white is going to play Queen
to d2 and possibly Bishop f4 we can
continue this line just for with this to
move the that are very natural and this
position is in fact much trickier than
it looks at first sight if you spot the
move rogue wave to my initial reaction
was I may also saw it like instantly
that you can take and I thought oh isn't
wish you just winning here is that since
is dead and no the thing is Jack this is
really fast and here it's not so clear
how black is going to going to play I
mean let's just consider just for
argument's sake and something like that
yeah the yeast got this ideas Queen here
let's say Bishop g7 ya go rook e1 there
is a there is some compensation on the
dark squares like that and maybe an odd
wasn't 100% sure if this is so great
especially if you consider if you look
at the game the game continuation he
played after look at this he took took
some minutes he played h6 and if you
look at this it it's also looking like a
very very good position for black it's
not like this rook f2 was an
out-of-the-blue single kind of chance
that you should take because it it's not
going to there's no no good to
alternative age six was also a very good
move I mean in terms of keeping keeping
an advantage black already has the
better structure and the bishop here you
don't need to do anything fancy am
immediately yeah h6 now slip late bishop
h4 looks like a strange move but but you
need to do it if you play a bishop III
normal looking with ace Queen f7 keeping
an eye on the square again and Bishop c7
is the threat basically trapping the
rook and winning the exchange white
cannot avoid
relieved you will win they exchange in
so Bishop to H flawless plate yeah and
here and you can calculate all kinds of
create these things 11 possible thing is
after this the screen move or you can
start here with g5 just to to be
complete about it here white can
sacrifice something you don't want to
try but after Queen f7 which is what
unplayed silhouette night h5 here the
computer actually suggests the move g5
which is for human player completely
insane to consider i mean we're always
amazed what what the engines come up
with if you just consider this
predisposition i can assure you that no
human player is going to do that as
black Bishop g5 check win takes with
check okay sidestepping check and i gave
the computer about a minute here to
evaluate this position and it's a pretty
pretty strong computer Houdini for non a
cut coin so also not like I'm using a
smartphone IAM and it gives them 0.54
black so slight edge for black so well
what kind of evaluation is that and the
thing is if you are human being and you
see that while your king is out in the
open and widest attacking with all those
pieces I mean it's just nothing you
don't play that especially if you if you
have a simple continuation that is not
anywhere near as risky he played Bishop
to e6 completing development but now
rookie three yeah but white I mean
White's position looks a bit clumsy but
he has quite a number of pieces near the
king and yeah it's my rook g3 needs to
be considered carefully SF 2 eggs but
yeah all pieces are some more somewhere
near the king
and if you give white yeah number of
kind of free moves to improve this is
this is not so bad now shut da twas
plate and let the ideas it after the
capture Jack you have f2 again and he
has Midler played rook f3 yeah now in
this position Aled went for an
interesting idea and oh I guess he was
maybe he was aiming for that even under
thought it maybe he has some some
chances in this position he know
sacrificed his Queen with Queen takes a
three after the capture he took on each
floor so he got luke and bishop for the
Queen and it is imaginable that he may
be thought he has something as black
because of all those pawns are
vulnerable you got a bishop pair and you
don't you're chronically nation as black
it's not terribly terribly bad um but
nevertheless I'm comparing it to some
other positions that we looked at
probably the the spot was sins the big
spot for improvement was still Brook
takes f-22 to get this important pawn
and they hang on to it in this in this
position it turns out that Sevilla after
King g2 and this moves he covered f3
with the rook from the side and then
after a couple of moves he started
counter play on the queenside and it
simply seems that black is not managing
to attack those pawns in a in a way that
white cannot defend them anymore the
counter play on the queenside he is
coming really quickly look at this sweet
Allah is insisting on simplifying the
position and I believe rightly so white
white has absolutely no winning chances
in this position he simply needs to be
careful that there is nothing nothing
terrible happening on one of those pawns
and well after b5 we see that
this is traded and yeah white simply has
this idea of a counter sacrifice here
after Bishop c63 that took on c6 and
after these moves they agree to a draw
he will just take a six and of course
there's nothing to do in this position
Black is just completely fine fine as I
completely coordinated and he can if
everything else fails simply always play
something like that and get the F
Freeborn back yeah it's this Queen
sacrifice wason what's interesting but
not sufficient to do anything in terms
of an advantage it's probably really the
case that maybe you can find something
around here it's the looks like I mean
g5 and I don't think so maybe you can
still find something around here but I
still believe that the crucial position
was really here where group takes f 2 is
probably the most viewer you must play
and I am pretty certain that if we were
in a situation here the tournament
situation where Anand needed to win the
game at all costs you would have taken
I'm very sure but he probably maybe he
saw some some more compensation that one
actually would have gotten I mean this
is not like check check yes as I had
shown this is really some compensation
it's not like white it's just a pawn
down for absolutely nothing but maybe he
overestimated that I believe that black
has stood quite good good chances to to
use this extra porn in the end but I
understand it from a human perspective
this might look tricky to you very very
understandable yeah okay certainly a
game well
ireland's positions right out of the
opening was that was excellent but maybe
he really needed to to yeah follow it up
with this capture on f2 to make a whole
point out of that not without taking
some risks but okay he's in a very
comfortable tournament situation and its
really understandable that he didn't
want to risk too much yeah okay let's do
a quick summary for both players after
this first part of the tournament or
let's say an evaluation of the standings
it's villas on fifty percent after this
up-and-down roller coaster ride win-loss
and so on yeah fifty percent is not a
hopeless situation if you compare it on
others on plus 2 so this is just one
point difference it's not like he's out
of the picture but he has made some
quite quite weird decisions already if
you remember this h6 move against man
would you are off which just blundered
the g6 born out of a position where he
was maybe even slightly better just
before it um he certainly could have
gotten more points that's no no question
but it's not completely out of out of
the race well Arnold is in a very
comfortable spot he's got this two wins
no loss he was never ever close to 0 to
even been worse and of course there is
the all-important game tomorrow in round
8 where we have the return game with
aronian playing white against her Anand
huronian the pre-tournament favorite and
note that Anand has won the first game
against uronian so if he would manage a
draw let's just be conservative here and
say Anand Ross's black against Aronian
then he would have the better tie break
because he won the mini match one and a
half 20 and a half and winning the mini
match means if they would finish on
equal points after this whole 14 rounds
then Anand would qualify due to the
better tie break having one
match which is I think a very fair tyreq
I mean you can always argue about those
mathematical things like okay he did win
against whom and somewhat this is always
a bit bit like black magic but if it
would end this way I Montana ronnian
finish on equal and are not won this
game okay then it's certainly a fair
deal yeah this would be super important
tomorrow and looking forward to to cover
that game and watch it alright thanks
for watching this video till tomorrow